diese sendung wird ihnen präsentiert von
b genießen sie cremige rezepte mit brk
monday cremiger genuss seit 1922
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir haben heute eine ganz besondere
person bei uns das schweizerische rote
kreuz hat eine botschafterin geschickt
es ist mir ein vergnügen euch dominik
vorzustellen mir eine große freude hier
zu sein
skirennfahrerin lewis wahrscheinlich
nicht was das ist
ich werde es euch später zeigen vor fünf
jahren habe ich die goldmedaille an den
olympischen spielen gewonnen
ich hoffe dass ich etwas für euch
verändern kann wenn ich in die schweiz
zurückkehren teure geschichte erzähle
ich danke euch herzlich für den warmen
empfang
[Musik]
die hand ist warm up unterlag jungs zehn
angriffe setzen dennoch fisch dann ist
ein green und du brauchst für
mineralischem engadin oder zwischen 4
und 11 ich bin ihm allerdings sieht und
wo man noch auf ein berggänger sehen
dieses einfach sie will meine großeltern
torschuss ferienoskar so viel familie
sagt sie und viele fehler
[Musik]
diese eltern haben diese immer sehr
unterstützt natürlich ist nicht einfach
sie auf ihnen zählte in dieser sportart
durch man im nachhinein realisiert was
sie alles verzichten müssen die den
verschnitt ferien wenn denn nur noch und
das ist natürlich schon vor ihnen als
opfer gesehen
[Musik]
wir uns gut
dominik ist sehr gut weg ist sehr
willkommen voraus also sich wirklich mit
sax männer den weg standen mit zehn
monate laufen
dominik im holz sehr früh auf sieg
stellte schläger ist mir sehr extrem
begeisterte skifahrer gesehen wir sind
wirklich bei jedem die möglichkeit sie
mir auf den keks
und sie hat natürlich sofort mit sorge
und super gefunden haben einfach
überlaufen und energy & water wenig ist
sie etwas lernen und selber zu bringen
oder und verarbeiten aber und heiß
gemacht hätten
[Musik]
doch noch besser und besser machen sie
karriere hat verschiedentlich angefangen
von ich & ich ja einfach sehr sehr gern
bei skisport kann in chicago geschickt
und nur 16 11 xi harry denz erstmal das
wichtigste rennen vom jahr der grand
prix final dafür für mich entscheiden
vreni schneider und mike von grünigen
kindheitshelden und die vereinigten
gestanden und haben das autogrammkarten
verteilt und mir den einbau die metaller
übergehen und das hat mich motivation
zum thema twitter und der bauer die
richtigen sicher extrem gesteigert
die zusagen nicht ein aber das rennen
gunnar harms der programmkinos in die
zentralschweiz zucker und die
zentralschweiz ist das ganze allerdings
vor dass fabienne suter 2 wk und und ich
nicht angereist und du darfst bin ich ja
nun inklusive internationaler einnehmen
und ich bete im jahr brauen im slalom
sehr sehr gut fahren und dann umgangen
werden soll war das internationale
rennen und bin hätte ich höre ja und ich
tue das denn vor der zentralschweiz und
steffi der tiger
[Musik]
eco mit ihrer regie nie war ganz der
alte mann so ich habe meine talente
gewinner tolle konkurrieren die wände
drückt aufs tempo astana ist verboten
war
in meinem schiff an den schweizer
[Musik]
hattest du einen guten flug
kompliment großartig hier ist unser
kleiner flieger
[Musik]
budapest
no one fine verbindlichkeit
zweifel
and the page
30 30
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs richtung split in
kroatien
dort halten wir um zu tanken und dann
haben wir noch eine wunderschöne etappe
vor uns
ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt es ist das
erste mal nach 19 jahren dass sich
sarajevo besucher und für dich für mich
ist es das erste mal seit 35 jahren
ja es ist sehr emotional für mich
für mich auch ich habe wunderschöne
erinnerungen an dieses olympische
abenteuer
danach kam der krieg und alles
veränderte sich dort diese schrecklichen
die machen mir angst dass der zauber von
damals kaputtgehen könnte
[Musik]
hier haben wir damals dieses foto
unserer ankunft gemacht hast du das
gesehen es schon heute an jedem tag da
war so viel schnee ich erinnere mich
noch gut wie viel die kurve wie sich das
verändert hat mir bleibt die luft weg
es waren so spießige häuschen
ich glaube die waren für die zeitmessung
oder für andere dinge im zusammenhang
mit dem wettkampf der sessellift war das
ziel
da waren so viele journalisten
ich war 18 jahre alt und ziemlich klar
diese vielen journalisten das hat mich
komplett überwältigt ich wusste nicht
mehr wohin ich sollte ich war irgendwie
vom brutto leventiner im tessin nach
sarajevo an die olympischen spiele
katapultiert worden
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
als ich nach sarajevo reiste hatte ich
all diese schönen bilder der stadt im
kopf wie im bilderbuch eine schöne stadt
mit bergen
als ich ankam fand ich eine komplett
zerstörte stadt vor
es war nur ein einziges hotel offen und
nur eine bank der der aufgebaut worden
war
[Musik]
das hat mich sehr berührt
ich war ja noch ein junges mädchen und
konnte für einen moment bildlich vor mir
sehen was ein glied anrichtet das hat
mich sehr geprägt in meinem leben
[Musik]
erinnerst du dich noch an dein gefühl
als du hier mit den ski ankam sind ja
aber ich denke es war für mich anders
als für dich klar ich durfte hier
skifahren
das war sehr wichtig aber ich erinnere
mich vor allem an die stadt an meinen
ersten flug mit gepäck das ist mir alles
viel präsenter als der wettkampf
es war ein wettkampf unter jugendlichen
das niveau war nicht so hoch
für dich war es anders würdig war sein
wichtigstes rennen
ich schwebte irgendwie über den boden so
emotional dass ich das erleben durfte
nicht nur die wettkämpfe sondern auch
das ganze drum und dran
das sind erinnerungen die mir
wahrscheinlich mein leben lang bleiben
will
[Musik]
euro
bis 30
[Musik]
wo bin ich denn in der zentralschweiz
interregional rennfahrer im slalom nach
dem ersten lauf mit kranich extrem viel
vorsprung geführt und bieten beste von
der jungsteinzeit der lauf an die eine
[Musik]
tänzerische nachwuchs zieht sich
aktionen die die ganz schwere
verletzungen
2001 2002 2003
wenn ich die zieht dann kriegt man keine
mega sollte so zurück wenn jetzt zurück
dank dem sinn von den stars bei sieben
starts bei sieben starts passiert
sondern sich einfach gesagt okay ich das
kreuzband gerissen und bei mir einfach
drei jahre lang verletzt gesehen wieder
verletzt sieht
[Musik]
wenn ich mich dann so jungen mit 14
verletzte clark sie dass das der große
traum monika skirennfahrer im 2 dass das
gesicht völlig neue möglichkeit wird
glaube das ist ein bisschen extrem
weitergebracht hat das frauen teil von
dem plan b ja sehr aktiv mitgestaltet
habe
[Musik]
wir finden in mathematischer begleiter
gefühl immer geben viel ruhigerem
kollegen ja ja das war ganz ganz lang
bissig aber ich bin eine breite porto
leonard ist mit abstand der intelligent
ist man schon ich kenne
wir sind einfach so klagt sie aber jetzt
wenn wir mit sicherheit das ist alles so
genau ist das
wir haben einfach so extrem inspirierend
noch ein physiker studieren wenn ich mir
überlege schon so viele stäbe und ich
habe auch ich mir halt nicht alles ganz
tief behält aber das zeigt mir ein
trüber tag also spezielle
relativitätstheorie haben wir alles
zurückbrachte
das weiß ich nicht verstanden die mir
die aufgabe gemacht mit dem auto und dem
äpfel so genau
das auto vater mario diesem auto und
dann hat man müsse zeit mal wieder
bürger sondern auch den mustern am auto
ist und das ist bis heute wenn
irgendetwas mich fragt was ist spezielle
relativitätstheorie
[Musik]
die c jugend wird nie 12 betriebs einig
sie bücher vom dalai lama und vom tisch
nathan gestoßen und habe auf
buddhistische literatur las er wirklich
völlig zufall will das böse der
bibliothek sie ist und wir gleichzeitig
voranschlag extrem viel über dritte
klasse hand über taxe verfolgen so klees
gefühlt ja das ist ein schwieriger und
schwieriger teil von der geschichte oder
religion und von der kulturen wenn ich
bin wie der buddhistische bürger eine
alternative gefunden wo mich sehr
angesprochen hat und wo mich wo mich
sehr fasziniert und dann bin ich mit
übertritts an idee mit stift euro also
ist gymnasium 20 jahren aus dem
zangenberg klosterschule
[Musik]
die protestantisch aufgewachsen also
reformiert und bitten die katholische
schule ist es unheimlich
schlüsselerlebnis sie wie porträts und
lehrerzahlen so viel von den
lehrpersonen damals muss ich mir die
jugendlichen auseinander gesetzt hat ist
eine frage mit ja ist eine kleine krisen
und und das hat mir so viel friede
eigene kultur wieder das ist bis ganz
ganz schön aus der schulzeit mit
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
da ich bin die burg ganz genauso
naja so gut läuft und läuft
während einer ruft alle dass sie
therapiert und ich sage man sich eine
von denen die leute über christ
wir haben natürlich autonomen und wurde
tun und somit einem fernsehprojekt ein
interesse an access oder und den henry
moskau dass sie um kate und dann haben
sie auch ihre jetzige homepage
hoffentlich hat sie sich nicht verletzt
dazu und dann als geist immer es wieder
operiert johannes bitter parierte
zweimal wir ja ja und wenn sie demnächst
ist ein unheimlich sagt auch jetzt ist
kurzsichtig
[Musik]
eine schöne option ist sie aber es hat
mir damals einfach mit bedeutet
unglücklich zu den großen zu einem
großen kindheitstraum
nicht immer komme
[Musik]
der kampf das ist die eigentliche nummer
muss klaus für das medizinstudium locker
bestanden und hat der svs werk macht
aber das sei alles nicht so dass da
wieder besser geht
der heilige und danke ja das ist sie es
ist mit fertigt sie für mich
[Musik]
sie ist wirklich stark sie im slalom und
unter der technische disziplin aber mit
ihrer verletzung wahrscheinlich der
slalom ist fast einer stunde für körper
und unterhaltung ist die schnellen
disziplinen sie automatisch dazu auch
hoch speed mit domenic scheint es für
mich klar dass sie nur spielt waren
und ich weiß auch nicht ob stand ein
bisschen zu sammeln so in erinnerung und
ich befürchte skilift in gefahr
32 oder zwei meter groß ich habe 3
annika wenig mit denen das war ein
wildes gehört am anfang aber sie ist
lernfähig und dass eine frau also wenn
man mit ihren vorschlag als quasi hat zu
sehr auf eine umsetzung
[Applaus]
und jetzt
bin ich hier und da ziehen sich die
chance für die mannschaft ist es
schwierig das intro bemüht und nehme ich
keinen tee und bier war nicht so
schwierig sich mit einem oscar für die
anderen teams empfehlen die situation
ist natürlich zehn jahren das ist immer
noch zu wenig gut will
es ist wie nicht gut genug dass die
andere blieb wiederum verkündigung es
ist nicht gut nur träumen freut
außer mir das ist so stark wie bier oder
und sie spielen wird das gefühl es ist
zu wenig und das gefühl von dem messer
am hals präsident setzt nicht auf denn
das macht oder wenn sich wieder dem
niemandsland wo ja so lang auf das zu
schaffen
die schüsse hätten sich aber nur bei
vancouver kreist über 20 grad in der
ersten woche alle trainings auszeit um
rang rückstand 1 die ganze ist das
einzige lacht sie und bennetts kreisel
city zumindest fordern
[Musik]
die frage dass ich die chance nutzen im
sand hc planung und koordination vier
jahre und bieten volk auf fahrer mit der
besten zwischenzeit auf medaillenkurs
zum leitspruch und wenn
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und den league steht dem ziel und ich
kann nur glücklich erwiesen oder leicht
generika aber richtig wirkliches
skifahrer hat sich in vancouver brauchen
[Musik]
die für leipzig vier wochen vorher noch
ein wenig dran gemacht da ist eine
riesen-enttäuschung sie aber trotzdem
alles geben das rennen in vancouver und
trotzdem bin ich so sexy dass sie dort
in vancouver die medaille hole und denn
ich war der letzte sprung war komplett
strukturen geklappt und ich habe auch
von der schuldige für kaboom welle
vollidiot überleitete und geschickt also
wenn es schicksal geht was ist mit dem
ziel liegend und nach allen wodurch es
ist das große talent sie dem verkäufer
im ziel liege
vancouver ist da härter vor mir in der
empathie versehen ich habe das richtig
hart mit ihrem untergrund ist folgende
menden über jahren strategie aufbaut wo
ihre sicherheit vermitteln vorbereitet
dass sie den kilos los und ans limit
kommen dass das bedürfnis ist für sich
ein er klar nichts finden indem will
dominik hätte die nach einer klaren
braucht damit sie können hinter verloren
[Musik]
im wald kurz nicht sein aber vielleicht
er hat es mir tut
ich hatte mir sich in allererster linie
was ganz großes vorbild ist gewiss nicht
alles war da noch machen sich darauf das
sehr anstrengend sie für sie
wahrscheinlich auch werde merck will ich
bin einfach mal was gesehen
[Musik]
er hat mich natürlich immer im
ministerium sehr junge schwester sind
verschwinden und sie hat praktisch
schwierige zeit von mir erlaubt wo sie
sehen macht xd ich immer dass sie sich
extrem praktisch dass ich immer so
verletzt dass es mir nicht so gut beim
sport und das ist eigentlich alle sehr
überrascht dass sie trotzdem drin zu
lassen
[Applaus]
diese
[Musik]
[Applaus]
den anfang zum mähdrescher frame sind
wodurch sich einfach versucht all meine
erfahrung und alles unikate mit der
leipziger mit berlin mit dem druck mit
der situation im irak war dass sie mit
ihren fehlern muss machen wenig dass sie
nicht die gleichen moment muss aber
nicht
ich spiele einfach wie von jahr zu jahr
wird weniger im sinn von anderes 60
vielleicht besser weiß noch nicht erst
mal taxi wirklich versteht jeder kurve
ist das auto zu dem punkt fahrer und
wenn dann sah ich dass jeder zweite
kurve mit so große augen gemacht und
jetzt ist schon sehr sehr professionell
sind vielmehr vor ich sehr viel
kapazität mehr und was er tat was sie
will als punktuelle moment wo sie zurück
wird und wenn ja unter anderem
randvollen griff
das ist richtig macht wir haben halt
einfach dem moment wo nicht einfach muss
zur los
aber das ist auch von clark ceo der
besichtigung in mainz ihr seid wie sie
schon mittags wieder auf denn du sie
einfach zuhören dann muss ich nicht
dabei als schwester verliebt und
diskutieren sondern ich ganz klar dass
das jetzt einfach zu lösen und zwar ganz
gut will das was immer seit werden
extrem viel hat man schnell
die motorrad sich die branche weg und
seine ja ich würde sagen es wohl coaches
corner
und schon aus zwei fordert aber von
total umstellen und einfach mit dem
pulver dass es auch in anderen perfekt
oder hat sie
die
sie sucht sparen nicht
ganz genau so ganz genau so
ich bin aber schon relativ früh
gestartet und lieferungen an also wenn
sie mich aber läuft und sie haben die
uns franzius auto kauft die fed kann man
in der stadt kameraleute und dann bin
ich dagestanden vorkommt und welche oben
und du und ich
die agentur ist was mache ich denn jetzt
dann ist vorher abbremsen und knochen
abbremsen
wenn wir über in voller marine sich so
luft trägt und bis ihnen nach nirgendwo
mehr ausgeschaltet sie war es vielleicht
noch eine gartenhütte nach 100 lage bin
dominik man könne dies schon sehr lang
und du hast es mir als klischee hält sie
mit lediglich rennen gegangen und den
autoren im skiclub sie und da früher
zweimal trainiert und dort aus dass man
bei diesen sind und auch freud keine
skifahrer haben sofort dazu aber
verbindungen sind gut miteinander und
ein viel zeit miteinander verbracht
ja man ist natürlich so wie das vorbild
ist sie schaut die schnapsidee stammhaus
und ich habe das so schnell fahren wie
sie und irgendwann sehen mit einem klick
rückzieher und haben zusammen trainiert
und mich an dem wir das ja lustig
verhältnis kabel müssen komplett wie
gegen und die haben oder sie schon immer
sehr fokussiert sie und ich bin ja noch
anders gesehen ist der skisport und vor
dem hci deepsea aber schon ein langsamer
freundschaft uns wurde aber ich glaube
meine jungs die sind schon fast mehr
kontur an
denn irgendwann also ganz ganz tiefe
freundschaft wenn ich ein moment
familiärem ist unser niveau
wahrscheinlich am meisten überrascht
denn ich glaube gerade da wo sie mich so
schwierig sich zum wieder anschluss zu
finden und eine mannschaft die für geld
insgesamt 13
sehr wichtige person sie das hat mir
extrem cool wenn ich mit jeder zahn auch
eine sie und vielleicht noch einer
hinterher oft stecken
umgekehrt hat sich der sache geben und
ich glaube sie haben unterstützen und es
hat sehr sehr vieles noch im fluss und
und sich dazu geführt dass ich mich
verschluckt basta und unfallchirurgie
versucht habe ich noch nirgendwo nicht
gar nicht immer passt
[Musik]
um 3 32 uhr ortszeit 21 und 30 schweizer
zeit ja endlich geworden geworden
der maler aber jetzt kann man doch war
das doch eine gute nachrichten hat viele
facetten abdeckt sie hatte das
verhältnis im vergleich zum teilen
gestern komplett anders gäste strahlten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also wirklich sicheren schrittes zu
recht am darunter richtungslos
[Musik]
ich glaube sie muss sowieso du das tor
also das sind halt ganz wichtig im
moment in der karriere
[Musik]
meistens nicht so im rampenlicht sind
aber das sind die wo die stärke machen
und das sind dir wo du extrem russland
und ich glaube michael sehr viel gelernt
verfügt und mehr und immer versucht das
oft bauer langfristig und das paar mal
ist es unglaublich wo gerade in lake
louise um es nicht erwartet hat und erst
mal auf die andere seite gibt und ich
glaube aus dem user geht es um heimat
vieles was ich damit meine für die
zukunft und für für die nach steuern und
für die nachstellung
[Musik]
also für mich ist sport und ganzen ganz
und große ladenburg sich sehr viele
dürfen wir sicher sehr viele rückschläge
erlitten und immer wieder müssen
aufstehen wenn ich aber zurück nur dann
muss ja sagen du bist und immer chance
im sport der bislang ob du wirklich bist
du musst lernen das ist ganz andere frau
und jeder ganzen anderen war der sport
ist ein land schulen aber es ist wie
jede schule
ob du am schluss klappt es wirklich oder
das hat auch jeder form wie du / und was
du musst macht ist
[Musik]
ich habe ich einfach das gefühl so groß
wie vor dem das wifo bis zum gerade auf
[Musik]
die sauberen start eine viele wie zeit
wenn das ziel wunsch bevor du oft
dörfler und schnell sich selber nur und
du musst es tolles ziel und ich alles
und bis zur sekunde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der basis
gehen sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
verfolgen sie vor leise was sehr schön
billig ist ein großer teil von dem warum
das hobby horse likes auf
[Musik]
wie sagt man danke level i bedeutet
danke und was heißt guten tag also in
berlin bedeutet danke und ähnlich guten
tag für organisationen engagieren
versucht weniger glück kommt als
mitbringen und das ist das ist skifahren
ist es kalt nicht zu heiß wie er ich bin
die kälte gewohnt
das ist die medaille das bin auch ich
mit der medaille
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
bei der österreich ist ein extrem
schwerer und bei jedem ecke stand nummer
100 franken ein anderes rolls und
schließlich schritte merken wie viel das
dahinter steckt ist schon nur die
schwingt das auch was anderes und aber
nicht nur andere leben das du ein star
aus sondern sich anderes wenn man
langfristig den anblick bewirkt und die
langfristige anderer gesellschafter
entstehen ich glaube da kann ja sehr
viel demut land
25 dürften für mich ich habe gehört das
haus sei aber was es braucht aber ich
bin am schluss muss man vor allem für
furor befähigen sich zu hause am will
diese nötige mütter und sich dann zu
sagen hat und sich viel näher als mit
ihnen wirklich mannschaft so gut und ich
glaube das kann mir sehr cool vor zum
bau dass wir mit gefühl haben spielt da
weiß auch nicht was alles andere
am schluss kann nur versuchen immer zu
haufen sich verkaufen
weißt du die männer bemerken eine schöne
frisur gar nicht normalerweise stehen
meine haare in alle richtungen ab und es
stört sie gar nicht zum glück bist du da
es ist jetzt viel schöner
also ich bringe euch jetzt ein wort auf
schweizerdeutsch bei
und noch eins
[Musik]
ja natürlich kann man so lange mit ganz
ganz kleiner mann ganz ganz große freude
machen ich glaube das ist dies nicht
anders spiels genau autogrammstunde kann
und es meinte hunt und verschießt
allergrößte in ihrem labor wenn sie
jetzt als autogrammkarte lieber hund
oder videos machen und ich glaube dass
man das einfach mir soll vergessen egal
wie gut dass dann groß dass man die
schlimme sache im leben nicht das vergaß
sie einmal mitgemacht hat
[Musik]
ihre größte user vor ist sie ihre eigene
band und der frieden finden
und ich weiß noch bis sport in ihre
karriere hat sie mir gesagt dass sie
habe vielmehr eine gute training was du
gleich und mit ihnen rücksicht und warst
du gleich bist du viel mehr
inspirationen für ganz viel lüth als
wenn du 20 oder 30 oder 40
aber ich merkte ich sie einfach an bord
lädt ein athlet in water wunsch viel sie
geht's vor allem
auch nicht nach mir gerade jeder mich
hat meldet sich für physik machen
habe ich das wirklich alles geben wenn
jetzt nur noch entscheiden für die
verschiedenen uni studieren weil es
vielleicht gerade so ein ruhiges tempo
war und natürlich auch schon müsse
feststellen
das ist ja das ist fast wie spitzensport
oder durch die beste jugendliche fast
ganz europa wo das volk auskennt und
alles wird wo die geniale stück
professoren innen mit band und sich
unglaublich bereichernd gesetzt und
kleinen blick erhaschen
aber wenn du nach der matura zuerst die
studium auch schon den abschluss und die
doktor und dem professor und dann mit 23
ski-fans rum mit 920 mit gewinnsprung
als versuch ist gleich noch mit dem
skisport und im wald gesprungen oder
dass ich das ist
zu sechst
[Musik]
es ist das permanente besser war aber
ich hoffe dass ich immer bis finde im
email aber nicht nur besser für andere
und neue bisher mitgestalten wenn das
nimmt wenn man nimmt freude an
mitgestalten und damit entwickler in die
övag ist dann ist für mich wie mit meter
und darum hoffe ich dass das immer bis
wird da sie bis an die vom im labor und
wenn es nur das lernen cello spieler mit
ski für mich das habe
[Musik]
diese sendung wurde ihnen präsentiert
von der genießen sie cremige rezepte mit
bergamotte cremiger genuss seit 1922